hi guys it's storm Reid here I'm going
to be talking about my first but make
sure you go see the Invisible Man
February 28th I'm so excited
first acting credit a sprouts PBS Kids
commercial that I did when I lived in
Atlanta and I had to like lay in this
bed and be woken up by a dog and super
cute first interaction with my you
phoria co-stars in day out my big sis Z
it's funny because I first met her in
2012 at Ben & Jerry's she was eating ice
cream with one of her good friends I was
getting my ice cream and I was on the
way to the movie so I was like kind of
in a hurry then I heard a familiar voice
so I turned around and I saw her and got
stuck for about a minute or two and then
I finally got the courage to go say
hello and that's when our relationship
started
we met at Ben & Jerry's and now we're
here first time you were starstruck the
time I met is in daya
I was literally stuck there for like a
minute or two and then my mom was like
you got to go over there or we're gonna
miss the movie so I went over I said my
name I don't really remember remember
what I said I don't think I've probably
even spoke English it was my first
starstruck moment first impression of my
wrinkle and time co-star Miss Oprah I
hadn't met her until we almost started
filming was pre-production and Miss Ava
actually brought me out of the room when
I was doing school and she was like I
have a surprise for you so I'm really
weird with the surprises cuz I don't
know what I'm getting myself into so she
takes me into a room and Miss Oprah was
sitting right there getting her hair
done and I go to introduce myself but
she was like and I freaked out because
she knew my name like I didn't have to
introduce myself
that was another starstruck moment of
mine and she was super nice and super
humble and down to earth so I'm glad to
have her in my corner now first memory
from the set of euphoria oh that feels
like such a long time ago my first
memory was probably one of the scenes
that means a Z did together
was just a chill scene of us just being
normal I guess and in being like big sis
and little sis
so that was one of my favorite memories
from the set because it was early on and
it was the pilot but it was also a time
where I felt most excited because I
wanted to work with her for the longest
amount of time so just to see my dreams
come to fruition was cool
the first time you realized you wanted
to pursue acting
I remember remember going up to my mom
she was sitting on the couch watching a
movie and I went to the left side of the
couch and I told her I was like mom I
want to be on TV and I want to be a
superstar so I don't know a lot of
three-year-olds that are walking around
saying what they want to do for the rest
of their lives so that's why I really
feel like that that that's my calling
first thought that came to my mind and
you read when they see a script I was
emotional um I was emotional for two
reasons I was emotional that Miss Ava
presented me with another opportunity to
be a part of such an impactful project
but also I was emotional because I
didn't know the story of The Exonerated
five before Miss Ava so I will forever
be proud to be a part of history and be
a part of that project first red carpet
event I think my first red carpet was
the 12 years a slave premiere and I wore
like this gold dress and I was obsessed
with Hello Kitty at the time so I like
well this cheetah print gold Hello Kitty
purse I thought I was the hottest thing
around town first career aspiration I
mean I think it was acting because I
started so young so that's what I've
always wanted to do but I think my
backup career aspiration was to go to
culinary school and become a chef first
favorite memory that comes to mind from
set of the Invisible Man we all went to
the Sydney Opera House and we had
and it was an amazing deal when we all
got to bond before we got on set which I
feel like is important to cultivate
relationships with people that you're
working with before you get in to doing
all these emotional hard things so
that's my my favorite memory first
cellphone I was just talking about this
the other day my first cell phone was a
flip phone I think I was around the ages
of 6 or 7 it was cuz my mom worked a lot
and she didn't feel like it was
necessary for me to have like a big-boy
phone or like a iPhone at the time but I
loved that phone I didn't know how to
text
there was no games but I just felt like
I was cool cuz I had a phone first
incorrect rumor you read about yourself
I try not to read comments or try not to
read rumors about myself but I did come
across one that was absolutely
outrageous I'm saying that I was
bleaching my skin I don't feel like I
was hurt because of course you know
something that outrageous is not
happening but I think I was confused and
like why would somebody write that first
role you really wanted but it went to
someone else I mean I feel like there's
a lot of roles that I've worked really
hard for and then I really wanted to be
a part of that particular project but I
learned from a very early age what's
meant for you isn't it for you and it
won't miss you and if it's not yours
then you don't want it so I'm glad other
people were able to get blessings and
I've been able to get other blessings as
well first piece of advice from Ava
Duvernay miss Ava that she gave you I
would say there was a time we were on
set it was after the forest scene and I
had to be dirty and wet so I didn't feel
like my shoes were dirty enough and she
said always look out for you
you and your character so I feel like
that was a great piece of advice because
that I really realized that you also
have to make sure that your characters
being portrayed in the right light so
that's something that I'll never forget
she probably doesn't even remember
having that conversation with me
something that stuck with me first time
you were recognized in public I don't
remember the first time I was recognized
but I can tell you the first time that I
was recognized tonight felt slightly
uncomfortable I was on the way to New
York I was in the restroom at the
airport and like the airport lounge and
I had to use the restroom really bad so
I like running the restroom and I'm
using the bathroom and someone says hey
are used to warm read so we end up
having an entire conversation I didn't
want to be rude but we had an entire
conversation lot while I was using the
bathroom which was pretty odd and that's
happened to me one more time after that
so that was interesting but I love
meeting people that I inspire and that
support me so I don't really think it's
that weird anymore
[Music]